the FEMA director comes out and does
this press conference I think it was at
the White House and she says we're
giving a onetime $700 payment to
everybody who's been impacted by the
Wildfire a onetime $700 payment Hawaii
has the highest cost of living in the
entire country and how freaking
insulting is it the lead Disaster
Response administrator from the Biden
Administration stand there and proudly
say hey we're giving everybody
$700 payment what's going on in Maui
right now is so sad what did they say
what's going on they're trying to take
the land the state is trying to take the
land the governor came out right after
the tragedy saying we're looking to see
if we can acquire the land and build a
memorial the amount of money would cost
to rebuild all those homes that burnt is
5 billion and the amount that they
accidentally over sent to Ukraine was 6
billion hell no why is it that our
federal government refuses to help
Americans and wants to help everybody
else